hello kids boys and girls ladies and
germs this is tim ferriss i'm going to
talk about
my mental models or how i think about
decision making and also
helpful and unhelpful intuition this
word gets used
and abused in a lot of ways so this is
my personal
take as far as decision making goes
there are a few tools or heuristics and
rules of thumb that i use quite a lot
the first is looking to make reversible
or fixable decisions as quickly as
possible you don't need to do a pro and
con list for a lot of things
you don't need to deliberate a lot of
things you don't need to make the
perfect decision for a lot of things
and if you want to preserve your
decision-making calories for the things
that actually matter and your creativity
then i try to make decisions that are
really
not mission critical in some way the
type of toilet paper to buy the type of
toothpaste to buy
i know people are going to debate all of
these right they could even seem like
big decisions like renting a certain
airbnb or whatever it might be
but if they are reversible let's say
they're easily cancelable you could get
a refund
or it's so inexpensive that you could
just buy a second
option then making those decisions
quickly and training yourself to do that
is a habit you need to cultivate
will save you a lot of energy so that
you're more
perceptive for the decisions that matter
a lot more or the stakes are higher
all right for then another set of
decisions let's just say one level up
i will use pro and con list but really
what i think is more helpful
is a risk benefit so you're writing down
sort of the best case scenarios and the
worst case scenarios for different
options
you could use that for choosing to
invest in a given company or not you
could use that for a million different
things
and if the downside is capped if you can
cap the downside
and there is asymmetrical upside meaning
you might make
2x 10x 100x 1000x
then you know at least your maximum
losses
okay so risk benefit i find more helpful
than pro con which can just be a laundry
list of different things to compare and
contrast i don't find that terribly
actionable
now layered on top of all of this
is what is sometimes called a whole body
yes
and i was exposed to this by diana
chapman and jim detmer
of the conscious leadership group i
think i'm getting
the name of the company correct and
this is what it looks like it's very
simple you're considering a decision
and you scan head heart
chest gut there are other ways to do
this
you could go to your loins too but let's
just say you're going with
head chest area heart and gut
you look for a yes signal a go signal in
all three areas that is the only
situation in which you should say yes
now what i find a little challenging is
identifying what a yes feels like
so what i do instead is i look for no
signals
what that means is if i feel any
contraction or grinding of the gears in
my head
it's a no if i feel any contraction in
my chest
or my chest area it's a no i feel
anything in my gut
it's a no all right these are
disconfirming
and where this is helpful is you can do
the risk benefit analysis you can do all
these types of analyses
and come to the conclusion that you
should do something something is a good
idea
but if it feels off i have learned to
say
no especially as it relates to people if
you just get
some spider sense intuition this is the
good case
the useful case that you shouldn't do
something or something feels
off say no so intuition i find most
helpful when it is pointing a different
direction from your analysis
okay so you believe you should do
something and your intuition says no but
you really want to do it
i would err on the side of listening to
what we'll call intuition
in this case if the math doesn't make
sense this doesn't make sense
but perhaps you should do it now this
financially only makes sense i think if
you have a lot
of money and you can cap your losses and
you have some investing experience
sometimes things can work out when you
just get a really good feeling about
someone you can also piss away a lot of
money so
caveat emptor the opposite and the
unhelpful form of intuition
i think which people use all the time
and certainly i've used
it's very very common to say my
intuition tells me to do x
my intuition tells me to do why i need
to listen to my intuition
when you're really just using that
sort of unassailable concept
right people can't debate your intuition
to do what you want to do
right so you haven't really taken any of
the proceeding steps
you haven't done any risk benefit
analysis
you haven't thought through the decision
you just want to do something
and then you use intuition as a
catch-all excuse or rationalization to
do it
that in my opinion is not intuition
that's generally just [ __ ]
so there you have it some tips for
decision making
and also my thoughts on good versus bad
or helpful versus
unhelpful often worse than that
self-defeating
so-called intuition
you